- It's over, Anakin. I
have the high ground.
- You underestimate my power.
- The force is very strong over at Disney,
which last week announced a
galactic federation's worth
of Star Wars content coming
to our big and small screens
over the next few years.
But don't you worry because
we're gonna bite-size
this bantha down for you
by focusing on three different titles
right now on The Ketchup.
Disney's Investor Day was a
cornucopia of content this year,
with over 50 new series
and movies announced.
When it was Star Wars' turn at the mic,
Lucasfilm's Kathleen Kennedy
confirmed two feature films
and 10 new Disney+ shows rolling out
over the next several years.
First up, Hayden Christensen
is reentering the Star Wars universe
for the upcoming Obi-Wan
series, starring Ewan McGregor.
Can you tell I'm excited?
Set 10 years after "Revenge Of The Sith"
and a decade before "A New Hope,"
the show will focus on Ben
Kenobi's lost years on Tatooine.
And I, for one, can't
wait to see how Obi goes
from looking like Ewan to
Alec Guinness in 20 years,
but maybe he forgot to
wear his two sunscreens.
Get it?
- I felt a great disturbance in the force.
- Kennedy teased that
the show would feature
a confrontation between the Jedi master
and his former padawan,
after the two last faced off on Mustafar -
a fight which cost Obi-Wan his faith,
and Anakin an arm and two legs.
Kennedy actually referred
to the showdown as
"The rematch of the century."
No disrespect, but it seems kind of like
an inaccurate assessment
of these guys' history,
considering the next time
Vader and Obi-Wan meet again
in "A New Hope," one of
them gets sliced in half
by a lightsaber.
Last time we checked,
it's hard to top murder
in the epic rematch
category, but who knows?
The long-awaited series,
which was allegedly
scrapped back in January
and put on hold while
the concept was retooled,
still has a number of question marks,
ranging from release date
to the number of episodes.
But low key, this kind of gives me hope
that maybe the Lizzie McGuire
series will come back to life.
But anyway, our number one question
is will James Earl
Jones make a vocal cameo
now that Anakin has his helmet on?
As far as what we do know,
the show will start
filming in March of 2021,
and at the helm is Deborah Chow.
Now, Chow recently directed
"The Mandalorian" Season
178 penultimate episode,
so we know she's good
at getting great
helmet-based performances.
- [The Armorer] This is the way.
- While the Obi-Wan series
will be sandwiched between
the events of the prequels
and the original trilogy, the
upcoming "Rogue Squadron" film
will be giving us our
most futuristic glimpse
into the Star Wars universe yet.
And no, we're not just talking
about the release date,
which right now is slated
for a very distant-sounding
Christmas 2023.
First formed by Luke Skywalker,
the Rogue Squadron has already
been the subject of games
and novelizations over the years,
but director Patty Jenkins
stated that her movie
will be an entirely original
story set in a future era,
introducing audiences to a
new generation of pilots.
As the first female director
of a Star Wars movie,
Jenkins is already pushing the
franchise in a new direction,
away from the Skywalker saga.
And in a Twitter video released
shortly after the Disney announcement,
she said that she was inspired
by her father's death in the Air Force
to make the greatest fighter
pilot movie of all time.
So expect more "Top Gun" than "Rogue One."
- That's one hell of a pilot!
- Before Rosario Dawson's
non-animated debut
in this season of "The Mandalorian,"
fans were rightly demanding to know
where the dank farrik was a Ahsoka Tano.
And now we know.
The beloved character
from "The Clone Wars"
and "Rebels" cartoon series
will be getting her own
live-action spinoff.
But first, some backstory.
Having been trained by
none other than Anakin,
Ahsoka never became a full Jedi,
instead defecting to help the resistance.
She later teamed up with a young Jedi
named Ezra Bridger after he
reached through time and space
and saved her from Darth Vader,
but lost contact after he disappeared
on a ship set to hyperspace
while fighting Grand Admiral Thrawn.
Now, in "The Mandalorian"
Ahsoka is still looking for Thrawn,
so we can assume that the show
will continue her quest to find Ezra
and suss out the Thrawn,
which could also tie in
with another upcoming Star Wars series,
"Rangers Of The New Republic."
But we'll have to break down "Rangers"
and the other new
series, "Lando," "Andor,"
"The Bad Batch," "The
Acolyte" another day.
Not to mention, the new, untitled
Taika Waititi Star Wars film.
And Disney clearly
wasn't done with the news
because they just announced
another spinoff series,
"The Book Of Boba Fett,"
coming to Disney+ in 2021.
Right now, little is
known about the series,
but stay tuned for more on that
'cause we'll be breaking down
what the finale of "Mandalorian" Season 2
means for the future
of Star Wars next time.
- There are too many of them,
what are we going to do?
- All right friends, it's time for us
to force throw it over to you, now.
Is this finally enough Star Wars content
to make your little heart sing?
Are you low-key upset that Jar Jar Binks
doesn't have his own spinoff yet?
I am. But let us know all
your thoughts and feelings
in the comments section.
And of course, if you want
more Disney investor news,
head on over to RottenTomatoes.com.
As always, we cannot thank
you enough for watching
another episode of "The Ketchup."
My name's Naz Perez, and
may the force be with you.
(upbeat music)